hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today i want to talk about the
occupation number representation
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics we already know that
bosons
are described by totally symmetric
states while fermions are described by
totally antisymmetric states
when working in the position
representation their states are
represented by permanence in the case of
bosons
and slater determinants in the case of
fermions if these names sound a bit
strange
make sure you watch the video on the
symmetrization posture before moving on
these representations are very useful
and they feature in techniques from
quantum chemistry all the way to
material science
and condensed metaphysics for example in
the shape of conchamp density functional
theory what we'll see today
is that this formulation has some
redundancy built in it
and as such is not ideal for some
applications what we'll see
is that the occupation number
representation provides an alternative
compact formulation to describe systems
of identical quantum particles
and it forms the basis of something
called second quantization which is an
extremely powerful tool
to do quantum mechanics so let's go
the basic idea behind the occupation
number representation is very
straightforward
so before we delve into the maths i want
to start by providing a simple intuitive
picture
imagine that we represent a system of
identical particles by a collection of
identical balls
and we pick a six-ball system also
imagine we have a shelf
and we label the levels as one two three
and four
an example of a state of our system is
given by two balls being in shelf one
one ball in shelf two three balls in
shell three
and no balls in shell 4. as these balls
are identical
i can exchange any two balls like this
and i will end up with the same
situation
so how can we describe these states one
way would be to assign a number
1 to 6 to each of these balls and then
say that level one contains both one and
two
level two contains bowl three level
three contains both four
five and six and level four contains no
balls
however we said earlier that exchanging
these two balls would not make a
difference
because the balls are identical so what
does that mean
in this description having exchanged the
balls takes me to the following
situation
level one now contains balls three and
two level two now contains ball one
level three still contains both 4 5 and
6 and level 4 still contains no balls
this now looks like a different
configuration of the system in levels 1
and 2.
but we know that in reality the
situation is the same because the balls
are identical and the labels artificial
so this description has some redundancy
built in and labeling balls is clearly
not a very good way of representing the
system of identical balls
in quantum systems of identical
particles if you check the video on the
symmetrization postulate you will see
that we have so far
built our state in a very similar
fashion we have constructed states by
first building an
n particle state in which we labeled
individual particles
and then applied the symmetrizer or
anti-symmetrizer to construct
all possible permutations of these
states ending up with expressions
containing
n factorial terms which as we will see
later in this video
also lead to a lot of redundancy both
examples suggest that there should be an
easier way of describing these systems
of identical balls or identical
particles
that captures the basic idea that
nothing changes when two identical balls
or two identical particles are exchanged
to see how this works in the case of
identical balls let's define the shelf
again
and place the balls again consider a new
description in which we only specify
how many balls are in each level
irrespective of which ball is which
so that in level one we have two balls
in level two we have one ball in level
three we have three balls
and in level four we have zero balls we
don't even need to draw the balls
because we already know they are
identical
all we need is the number of balls in
each level
this is precisely the sort of
description we're looking for when i
exchange
any two balls like this the number of
balls in each level stays the same
so this description also stays the same
and we don't have any redundancy
put another way in this first case we're
trying to characterize our system by
asking the question
which ball is in which level because the
balls are identical this leads to a
highly redundant description as
exemplified by these two permutations of
numbered balls
instead in the second case we're trying
to characterize our system by asking the
question
how many balls are in each level this
avoids assigning labels to otherwise
identical balls and provides a more
compact description of the system
in quantum mechanics the occupation
number representation is analogous to
the second situation
rather than associating each particle
with single particle state
and then constructing the symmetrized
and anti-symmetrized states with n
factorial terms containing all possible
permutations of particles
we describe states using the number of
particles that are present in a given
state
irrespective of which particle it is
in the rest of the video i will make
these statements mathematically precise
but the basic idea is the one presented
in this slide
let's consider a system of n identical
particles whose state space v
is the tensor product over the n single
particle save spaces v1
to vn let u be a set of states forming a
single particle basis
and i want to start with a refresher on
some background needed to study the
occupation number representation
if you want for the details you can find
all the necessary videos linked in the
description
you will remember from the video on
tensor product spaces that we can
construct the basis for the tensor
product space v
by calculating the tensor product of the
basis states of the single particle
spaces like this
as usual we will emit the tensor product
symbol moving forward and simplify our
notation to this
this here is a basis for v but we know
from the video in the symmetrization
postulate
that the states describing a system of n
identical particles
don't really live in v but in one of two
subspaces of v
if the particles are bosons they are
described by totally symmetric states
such that any permutation p
alpha doesn't change the state and these
psi
plus totally symmetric states span the
subspace v plus
if the particles are fermions they are
described by totally anti-symmetric
states such that under any permutation p
alpha we get eta alpha psi minus state
in the subspace
v minus in this final expression eta
alpha is plus one for even permutations
and minus one for odd permutations which
remember means that exchanging pairs of
particles an even number of times gives
back the same state
and exchanging pairs of particles an odd
number of times gives back the negative
of the initial state
we also know that to obtain a state in v
plus all we have to do is to act with
the symmetrizer s
plus up here on arbitrary state in v and
similarly to obtain a state in v minus
we act with the anti-symmetrizer s minus
all this means that if we want to
describe an n-particle system of
identical particles
we don't really want the bases in v like
we have here
what we want are the basis states in v
plus and v minus
so how do we build these basis states as
you may guess
they are simply obtained by applying the
symmetrizer and antisymmetrizer to the
basis state of v
let's see how this works for v plus
start with an arbitrary state
psi in v acting with the symmetrizer on
psi we obtain a state in v
plus as psi is a state in v then we can
write it in the basis of v
like this and remember from the video on
representations that the c coefficients
are the representation of the state psi
in the u basis we can then build the
state in v plus by acting with the
symmetrizer on both sides of this
expression
and we obtain s plus psi on the left and
s plus acting on the sum on the right
the symmetrizer is a linear operator so
we can move it inside the summation
and we get this long expression
so what does this mean a state in v plus
can be expanded in terms of basis states
that are given by the action of the
symmetrizer on the basis states of v
this means that as expected when we
symmetrize the v basis we obtain a basis
for v
plus we can of course make an analogous
argument to find that when we
anti-symmetrize the v basis we get the
basis for v
minus as we just found this symmetrized
and anti-symmetrized basis states from
bases
for v plus and v minus but as you may
suspect there is a lot of redundancy
in these basis states the full state
space
v is defined by the tensor products of n
single particle states
but v plus and v minus are
non-complementary subspaces of v
so their dimension is smaller than that
of v
if we simply apply the symmetrizer or
antisymmetrizer on every single basis
state of v
then we will get as many basis cats as
the dimension of v
which is many more basis sketch than the
dimensions of either v plus or v minus
this means that this set contains
repeated states and we would ideally
want to build a new basis for v plus and
v minus
that doesn't contain repeated spaces
states
before we can remove the repeated states
we first need to figure out which states
are repeated
given that we're dealing with systems of
identical particles we can already
suspect that the states that will be
repeated will correspond to different
permutations of a given state
to confirm this consider basis state in
v
then apply an arbitrary permutation p
alpha to obtain another basis state in v
from them we can build two basis stage
in v plus all we have to do is to apply
the symmetrizer
and the first one gives this while the
second one gives this
looking at this relation up here that we
derived in the video in symmetric and
anti-symmetric states
we see that s plus p alpha is simply s
plus
so we obtain this as expected this state
and this state are the same state in v
plus
this means that these two distinct basis
states in v
give the same basis state in v plus we
can of course make a similar argument
about v minus and we reach the same
conclusion
up to a minus sign in the definition of
the basis
put another way any permutation of a
basis state in v
gives the same basis state in v plus or
v minus
this is the origin of the redundancy
that we have in the basis for v plus and
v minus when we build them
by symmetrizing or anti-symmetrizing a
basis of v
but this makes perfect sense
permutations of identical particles
don't change the physics so any
permutation of a basis state in v plus
or v minus
should give the same basis state
so we have just found that if we
consider any permutation p
alpha of a basis state of v then the
basis states in v plot or v minus that
we obtain by applying the symmetrizer or
antisymmetrizer are repeated
this means that the representation
provided by these bases is not ideal
for studying systems of identical
particles because there is a lot of
redundancy
and it motivates us to introduce a new
representation called the occupation
number representation
so what do we want for this new
representation because we're dealing
with identical particles any permutation
of a basis state in v gives the same
basis state in v plus or v minus
therefore we're looking for some
quantity that is the same in any
permutation of a basis state
consider a single particle basis u and
spell it out as u1 u2
and so on to build the basis scat of v
we need to take a tensor product over
n single particle states as usual but
now i will build a very specific tensor
product basis state in which i will
first write out
all the particles in single particle
state u1
and i imagine there are n1 such
particles then i will add all the
particles in single particle state u2
of which there are n2 and so on
we call the number of times that an
individual state appears its occupation
number
and this means that the occupation
number of u1 is n1
the occupation number of u2 is n2 and in
general the occupation number of state
uk
is nk put another way out of the total n
particles the occupation number
and k tells us how many of those are in
state uk
what we're going to do is to associate
this list of occupation numbers with
this particular basis state
next let's consider a permutation p
alpha of this state we just wrote
the question now is what are the
occupation numbers of this new state
all the permutation does is to reorder
the terms but it doesn't add or remove
any single particle states
so the state you u1 still appears n1
times state u2 still appears n2 times
and so on this means that we can
associate the exact same list of numbers
with any permutation
of a basis state of v but this is it
we were looking for a quantity that is
the same for any permutation of a basis
state of v
and we just found that these lists of
occupation numbers are one such quantity
so what will happen when we apply the
symmetrizer anti-symmetrizer to these
two states
the symmetrizer and antisymmetrizer are
simply sums of permutation operators so
they will move around the states
but will not add or subtract any states
so after projecting onto v plus or v
minus
we will still have the same list of
occupation numbers for the resulting
states
this means that we can characterize all
permutations of a state by their
occupation numbers
as these permutations are responsible
for the repeated states we found
in the basis of v plus and b minus this
means i can directly use occupation
numbers
to uniquely label the basis state of the
symmetric and anti-symmetric subspaces
removing all redundancy we originally
had
this leads to the definition of the
occupation number representation
we write the state n1 n2 and so on
as the symmetrized or anti-symmetrized
state of a corresponding basis state
in v here i picked the ordered state for
convenience but from our discussion we
can pick
any permutation p alpha we want of this
state and it will lead to exactly the
same definition
of the occupation number representation
this all makes perfect sense because
we're dealing with identical particles
so it shouldn't matter which permutation
of the particles we use
there is a final detail in the
definition of the occupation number
representation
we will want to work with normalized
states so we'll write a normalization
constant in front here
a plus minus a few points before we move
on
first it immediately follows that the
total number of particles is equal to
the sum over all nk
second it could be that there are no
particles in a particular state so the
occupation numbers may be zero
all we have left to discuss are the
normalizations calculating them is
tedious and not a very enlightening
process
so i will not do it in this video i have
linked a reference in the description
where you can find the details or you
can try it out yourself
for our purposes all we need is the
answer if we start with bosons
then the occupation number
representation of the state
is given by the square root of these
factorials
and then the symmetrizer acting on the
tensor product basis state
the main question when looking at an
occupational number state for a boson
is how many particles occupy a given
state
this is an example of a boson occupation
number state
and what this means is that there are
two particles in single particle state
u1
so that n1 equals two then zero
particles in u2 so that n2 equals zero
three particles in u3 so n3 equals three
six particles in u4 so that n4 equals 6
and so on
in general we have an infinite number of
single particle states u
but only n particles this means that
many of the occupation numbers will be
zero
like in this example we had n2 equals
zero which meant that no particles were
in the single particle state
u2 to simplify notation rather than
writing the occupation number state like
this
with n1 and 2 and so on what is
typically done
is to write out only the occupation
numbers that are occupied and it is then
understood that the ones that are
emitted have zero occupation
so instead we will write n i and j and
so on
where n is the first occupation number
that is non-zero and j the second one
and so on
now let's turn to fermions in this case
the occupation number state
is given by the square root of n
factorial of the anti-symmetrizer
applied to the basis state of v
if all ui are different and it is zero
if any two ui are equal remember that a
totally anti-symmetric state that we
represent as a later determinant in the
position representation
vanishes if two particles are in the
same state this is reflected by this
expression and the main question for
fermions becomes whether state
is occupied or not the occupation
numbers can only take values of 0 or 1
so this is an example of a framionix
state and the corresponding occupations
are n1 equals 1
n2 equals 0 n3 equals 0 n4 equals 1
and so on just like in the case of
bosons we can write the occupation
number state like this
or we can also meet all the zeros and
simply write down the occupied states
like this
however given that for fermions
occupational numbers of occupied states
are all one
then rather than writing the ends we can
directly write down the corresponding
single particle state label
what this final expression is telling us
is that the states that have exactly one
fermion
are u i u j and so on
another critical point about fermions is
that the order is important this is
because fermions are described by
totally anti-semantic states which are
defined like this
this eta alpha is the parity of the
permutation
which you will remember from the video
on permutations that it is the parity of
the number of transpositions into which
you can write
out a permutation what this means is
that exchanging any two fermions
introduces a minus sign
and the ether is telling us that
exchanging pairs of fermions an odd
number of times introduces an overall
minus sign
and exchanging pairs of fermions an even
number of times leaves the state
unchanged
if we consider framinic state like this
and now exchange the two first occupied
states like this
then this action is represented by a
permutation that only exchanges the
first two particles and leaves the rest
invariant
which means it is a single transposition
so in this case eta is minus 1
so we need to introduce a minus sign in
this equality
so what have we accomplished with the
occupation number representation
let's compare the two representations in
this formulation
we specify the single particle state
that each particle occupies
and then after applying the symmetrizer
or anti-symmetrizer we end up with
n factorial terms in the calculations
containing all possible permutations of
the n particles in our system
the resulting expressions are there for
very long for example in the position
representation in terms of wave
functions for bosons they take the form
of a permanent
and for fermions in the form of isolated
determinant however
at the end of the calculation many of
these terms will cancel or be the same
because the indistinguishability of
identical quantum particles introduces a
lot of redundancy in this description
this is equivalent to the case in which
we labeled the balls in the example at
the very beginning of the video
that also proved to have a lot of
redundancy built in it
the occupation number representation
resolves this problem the relevant
quantity when we have identical
particles is not which particles
but instead how many particles occupy a
state
this makes perfect sense we have a
system of identical particles which are
indistinguishable
so assigning labels to them is
meaningless this is precisely what one
would expect for a compact formulation
of the physics of a system of identical
particles
and this is why the occupation of
representation is so powerful
the occupation number representation
leads to a very powerful formalism
to study systems of quantum identical
particles called second quantization
to learn more about second quantization
well you should check out the videos on
fox space
and on the creation and annihilation
operators that allow us to explore
that fox space so why would you want to
learn more about second quantization
it is the tool that allows us to study
quantum systems in which the number of
particles isn't fixed
for example in relativistic quantum
mechanics so called
quantum field theory or in quantum
statistical mechanics
if you liked the video or would like
send me suggestions for future videos
please subscribe